hey what's up my name is samuel leagues
in this video i wanted to talk about
some of the things
that we grow up being told the sayings
the idioms
the expressions which i believe are not
only not true
but will also hold you back and clap you
from being successful and great in
business
so these are a few of them i'd love to
know what you think so comment below if
you agree with me
if you disagree with me if there's more
that i didn't think of
the first one and this is really really
this really gets when people say this
that's when they say you can't have your
cake
and eat it too you know so you're trying
you're trying to
you know win twice you want to buy a
house and you want to get cash flow from
it and capital appreciation
you can't every cake and eat it too you
can't have it
you can't have it all but actually
here's the thing right not only is that
not true
but the saying is completely ridiculous
because
what's the point of having a cake if you
can't eat it too
what are you gonna do just look at it
it's absolutely absurd
yeah we just grow up hearing this kind
of thing next one we hear all the time i
heard this all the time growing up and
that's
if it sounds too good to be true it
probably is
you probably heard this as well you've
probably heard this
if you've heard that saying before let
me know in the comments let me know in
the comments
if you disagree with that saying let me
know in the comments i disagree
here's here's why if it sounds too good
to be true it probably is so here's what
happens society
sets your expectations for average
you're at school as a kid
you want to be an astronaut you want to
be a footballer you want to be a
multi-millionaire business owner you
want to be a property
mobile and they'll kick that out of you
and say
no no you need to go to university get a
job
live a normal life and you'll be
brainwashed and programmed for normality
and then as soon as something comes
along that's different and good
you think wow can you really live life
like that you then have this stupid
quote if it sounds too good to be true
it probably is let me tell you something
if you
live by that standard if it sounds too
good to be true probably is
nothing good will ever come your life
nothing good
and in fact if something good does come
along you'll sabotage it
even if you're subconsciously sabotaging
it because you'll be thinking oh if it
sounds too good to be true it must be
too good to be true and
it doesn't exist a good relationship
will come along i mean when i first met
my wife
i'm like damn she's amazing imagine they
fight about that mindset
sounds a bit too good to be true what
would i've done i'd have walked away
because i thought it wasn't true i've
not
been happily married for six years we've
got two kids we've got a third one
jew in a couple of days bye wow
so don't don't take that crap it sounds
too good to be true it probably is
next one number three they say seeing is
believing
you know seeing is believing i'll
believe it when i see it
i completely as a property developer
as an entrepreneur completely disagree
with that
because actually you have to believe it
first before you can see it
if you're building a development site
you don't say i'll believe it once it's
built
no no you have to see it first you have
to believe it's gonna happen
you have to visualize it and then go
make it happen
so you know seeing is believing i
disagree i think believing is seeing
you believe it first and then you
manifest it into reality
of course with hard work along the way
so next thing
let me know what you think but if you
enjoyed this video smash the like button
if you agree with me
smash the like button if you want to
share this around let other people know
share it because people need to know
this they need to be unbrainwashed from
these
nonsense statements and lies of society
all right next is this
money doesn't grow on trees you heard
that
what do you think i'm made of money
money doesn't grow on trees i mean
what's the problem with that i mean is
it true does money grow on trees
well i guess technically paper money the
thing that people think is money
the ious that actually literally does
grow on trees which is kind of ironic
but here's the problem with that
if you said money doesn't grow on trees
what you're actually saying is
it it takes iceland it takes money to
make money
money is not unlimited it doesn't just
grow on trees
it's hard to make money it takes years
to build savings
that whole mentality is a lie there's an
unlimited amount of wealth in the world
you know money goes around you can make
you can make money
not by taking money off somebody but by
giving value to somebody
you know so this whole mentality money
doesn't go on trees
you know it takes money to make money it
doesn't there's an unlimited amount of
wealth in the world
and there's so much money in the world
for someone to just be making 2
000 a month from working their ass off
for it doesn't make any sense so i don't
like that i don't like that one
all right next watch the pennies and the
pounds will look after themselves
i don't like that one either why because
if you focus so closely on the pennies
you're going to miss the million
what you focus on expands and this whole
mentality of
you know watching the pennies and being
careful and playing it safe
that's not what made me a millionaire i
started from scratch started with
nothing
working class backgrounds single mom no
one gave me any money i became a
multi-millionaire
how because i didn't have this mindset
of watching the pennies i had this
mindset of
how can i solve big problems how can i
make millions of pounds
um all right next bad one don't talk to
strangers
you've probably heard this don't talk to
strangers and then people wonder why
they can't get new business
why they can't find a joint venture
partnership because they've been
programmed
to not talk to strangers it's not easy
money is very limited and small and it's
hard
and it's all nonsense all right last one
this one's a little bit different
um and this one this is this is when you
ask people how they're doing and they
say not too bad
not too bad are you kidding me
i don't want to die and have on my
tombstone samuel
not too bad leaves i want to i don't
want to be not too bad
again that's the normal pay me fine not
too
bad that is normal let's break
normal when people say how you doing say
i'm great how are you doing
i'm awesome i'm excellent how are you
doing
just break these these silly idioms and
these these mindsets and these
statements
because i honestly think that not only
are they incorrect but they're also
keeping people enslaved financially and
keeping people poor
anyway let me think in the comments if
you like the video smash smash like
share it around and i'll see you next
time